this teacher is given a class of
teenagers to teach dictatorship but his
unique way of teaching brings unexpected
outcomes and almost shuts down the whole
school rer Wenger is a middle-aged High
School teacher he works at the same
Institute as his wife anky so things are
pretty stable and peaceful the project
week has started and rer is expecting to
get the class of Anarchy as he is an
expert in that but due to his late
submission of the project outline this
subject is given to someone else Rainer
tries to convince the head of Department
to give him another chance no one in the
school can teach Anarchy better than him
the head can't do anything right now so
rer tries to talk with the current
Anarchy teacher rer requests to exchange
subjects But the teacher is not willing
at all at the end Rainer just accepts
his fate and prepares to teach the
opposite subject that is autocracy he's
always excited for the project week but
the students don't take it seriously
they spend most of their time hanging
out in clubs and randomly choose the
subject for the project week as Monday
arrives rer greets his autocracy class
and gets shocked to see so many students
he would have never chosen this subject
if he were in their place but he is
willing to teach them passionately the
lesson starts with a basic question what
is autocracy surprisingly most of the
students don't know the answer so rer
explains it in easy words autocracy
comes from the Greek and means self-rule
in an autocracy the ruler has unlimited
power to change the law as he likes
which can also be referred to as
dictatorship most of the students show
lack of interest in this subject as they
believe that another dictatorship would
be impossible in Germany rer is ready to
change their point of view within this
week he gives them a 10-minute break and
when the students return the seating
arrangement has been changed then he
asks the students about the requirements
of an autocratic system all the students
give different answers and rner
appreciates them all afterward he says
that they are going to do a small
activity in which they will try forming
an autocratic system in this class every
dictatorship has a central figure so
Rainer vodes to choose the leader and
the majority of students agree to let
rer be the leader as he is the leader
now he deserves respect therefore the
students must call him Mr Wanger from
now on moreover no student is allowed to
talk without permission he must raise
his hand and then stand up to speak when
the students call it getting too far rer
convinces them by explaining that
standing up improves their blood
circulation and concentration in lecture
he even instructs them to sit properly
with their straight back and breath
deeply an upper class student named
Kevin finds the activity a little weird
and he refuses to do it rer gives a
choice either play along or leave the
classro Kevin chooses the latter and
also takes away his friends cenan and
bomber but bomber is already having low
grades so he joins back the class with
Cen rainner continues The Lesson by
asking about the social conditions that
favor a dictatorship a shy student named
Lisa wants to answer but she can't
choose the best words Rainer advises her
to take a deep breath and keep her
answer short and precise this works and
Lisa gains more confidence a timid boy
and insecure boy named Tim also enjoys
the lesson and rer becomes his favorite
teacher after the lesson students get
back to their home as well as Rainer an
is delighted to see that Rainer is
enjoying the lessons despite his hatred
towards it his words have a different
impact on different students some
literally forget it while some are
thinking really hard the one who got
influenced the most is Tim the whole day
he keeps talking about how great Rainer
is an intelligent student of the class
named Carol also mentions about the
discipline lessons in her house but her
parents are way too cool they advise
Caro to live recklessly but Carol is
secretly against that she wants to get
away from her family for a while and
decides to go on a trip she tells about
it to her boyfriend Marco but he doesn't
seem interested and leaves to practice
sports he's a part of the school's water
polo team Marco is not doing well today
because he is busy in thoughts doubting
his relationship with Caro she is a
dominant person who always decides
everything everything without even
asking Marco meanwhile Rainer stays up
during the night to gather more fun
ideas he can try with his students the
next morning as he enters the class he
asks the students to do some light
exercise then rer teaches them how to
stomp in unison as their coordination
gets better the noise gets louder this
activity will help them learn about the
power of unity rainner playfully reminds
them that their enemy the Anarchy
classroom is right under them realizing
this the students stomp their feet even
harder after the exercise rer changes
the seating arrangement once again he
puts the students with lower grades with
the bright students one of the students
says it's an embarrassment to the poor
students but Rainer explains that no
students are poor everyone is good in at
least one subject so they can help each
other during the break Rainer is called
by the principal because of the noise he
caused in the morning but a few students
interrupted them because they wanted to
shift to rainer's class the principle
realizes that Rainer is grabbing
students interest so he lets him go rner
continues his lesson and tells tells the
students that Unity can be encouraged
with uniforms not just in school but
also in organizations like the military
or the fast food chains have a uniform
rer suggests they have a uniform for the
project week not anything expensive just
a pair of blue jeans and a white shirt
one of the students protests that he
doesn't have white shirt and doesn't
want to spend money buying it luckily a
kind student named yens offers to give
away one of his spare white shirts but
actually Jens doesn't even have one and
secretly buys two white shirts s Lisa
spots him and gets impressed by Jen's
big heart however Tim has taken the
lessons too seriously and burns down all
of his branded clothes because rner
talked against the big Brands the next
day all of rainer's students are wearing
the same attire except for Cara as she
thinks she doesn't look good in white
new students join in and rner is
delighted to see a fully crowded
classroom he believes that they deserve
a name all the students give suggestions
and Rainer writes them on the board he
let the students vote and the chosen
name is the wave now rer wants everyone
to contribute to this team he chooses a
student to design a logo while another
student volunteers to create social
media platforms for the wave everyone
gets really excited and starts
discussing more ideas they haven't
realized how much team spirit they have
developed later that day Tim gets
bullied by a bunch of dro addicted
students but his white shirt gets
spotted from afar so Sinn and bumber
Rush there to help him rainer's efforts
are paying off and he has turned his
class into a gang but Caro keeps getting
ignored because she refused to wear the
dress code Marco is also sick of her
bossy nature and wishes her to become a
part of the wave Caro isolates herself
and also gets replaced from the school
play The Wave is getting stronger even
outside of the school senan convinces
Kevin to join them again and also forces
other students and even Caro's younger
brother join the wave Lisa visits Caro
and tells her about the play replacement
she also says that Caro should value
Marco's opinion as she may lose him too
car doesn't like that Marco is
discussing their relationship with
others and she gets angry with Lisa poor
Lisa is fed up with Caro always being
the spotlight and she ends their
friendship later that night Rainer tells
his wife about students efforts to
promote the wave but anky is not happy
about this she believes that rer is
taking it too far and it may bring
negative outcomes she is right the kids
are getting totally obsessed with the
wave they gather in the middle of night
and paint their logo almost everywhere
they don't even spare the police car
they also want to paint on a new famous
building but it's too high Tim
volunteers to do it and climbs up other
students run away on seeing the police
but Tim stays behind and paints the logo
the next morning the students also
decide to have a unique salute that
represents their group and rainner loves
it too Caro is getting more frustrated
and decides to stop it but the students
don't leave inside the class without the
uniform and the salute she proceeds to
talk to Rainer and requests him to think
about it carefully rner doesn't see any
harm and advises Caro to change her
subject if she doesn't like it Rainer
gets back to the staff room but all the
teachers including anky seem distanced
from him rner goes to the principal and
tries to explain that he has an
educational goal the principal is
actually not against it all she is
loving how the students are developing a
bond and they are so eager to come to
school she advises rer to ignore other
teachers as they may be jealous
meanwhile Carol hasn't given up and asks
the school newspaper team to give her
the list of students email IDs she plans
to email everyone and encourage them
against the wave later that night Tim
and other wave members were hanging
around when they encountered a gang of
punks the students have painted The Wave
logo on the Punk's artwork which made
them angry they all start fighting but
all of a sudden Tim pulls out a gun the
punks run away in fear but the students
are also wondering why Tim has a gun Tim
Just Smiles and explains that it's a
fake one the next day Caro discusses
with her friend how to stop the wave
suddenly Marco walks in and invites Caro
to join a party near the lake she
refuses saying that she doesn't want to
get involved with the wave as it's
getting extremely day by day she even
shows him some online posts about the
wave forcing students to join them Marco
gets frustrated as he thinks kro is just
overreacting he doesn't want to leave
the wave it means a lot to him because
he never had a supportive family he
leaves after saying this and Caro is
alone again but things are actually
getting extreme especially for Tim he
randomly shows up at rainer's house and
offers to be his bodyguard rer tells him
to just go home but Tim explains that he
doesn't have a loving family Rainer
takes pity on him and lets him stay for
dinner later that night Carol sneaks
into the newspaper Club room and tries
sending out the emails unfortunately it
keeps giving an error Carol changes
plans and takes out prints of her
article she throws them around the
school and goes back home meanwhile the
other students are having a party near
the lake Lisa takes this as a chance to
hit on Marco and tells him that he
deserves better than Caro their romantic
moment is interrupted by cenan as he
wants to invite everyone to watch their
final game against the other schools
team as rer is their coach the wave must
show up to support their leader Cen also
tells them to bring more people but all
of them must follow the dress code the
next morning when rer steps out of his
room he finds Tim sitting there the
weird kid stayed there all night Rainer
advises him to be mature and they both
head to the school the wave members have
already found the Flyers Caro through
they know she is the one behind it and
asks Marco to talk to her as soon as
possible afterwards they go to attend
the autocracy lesson today rer is really
angry as he watches news about the logos
painted all over the city he scolds the
students for crossing their limits and
asks them to write down what they have
learned in this project week after the
class they all head to the pool to watch
the game K also arrives but the entrance
is blocked she must wear the wave shirt
to enter Kora refused uses and sneaks in
through the back door she throws around
her Flyers which starts a fight the game
is dismissed and all the blame is put on
Rainer even her wife ank is upset about
how far he took the lesson in
frustration Rainer shouts at ank and she
packs her things and leaves the house
meanwhile Marco goes to talk to Caro but
she is determined to end the wave Marco
gets angry and hits Caro he immediately
feels guilty and heads to rainer's house
Marco requests him to stop this thing as
the wave is turning them into extremists
rer agrees and calls a meeting with his
group all the wave members Gather in the
auditorium and the doors are locked
Rainer reads their feedback all students
wrote that the wave made them equal and
gave a meaning to their lives afterwards
rer announces that they can't let anyone
put an end to the wave they are going to
take over Germany hearing this Marco
stands up to protest but Rainer calls
him a traitor he orders them to bring
him to the stage and let the students
choose the punishment
all of them start cheering up rer tells
them to shut up and see what they have
become they are ready to sacrifice their
friend just because their leader said so
they assumed themselves special and
excluded others who didn't agree with
them they are manipulated by rer that's
how dictatorship Works their lesson is
over now and so does the wave the
students finally realize the whole
situation and prepare to leave but Tim
pulls out his gun to stop them bomber
walks forward as he believes that the
gun is fake but Tim shoots him then he
points at rer and says that the wave was
his life rer explains that if he kills
him the wave will end without a leader
after realizing this Tim puts down the
gun but then he suddenly shoots himself
to deth the police arrive and they
arrest rer he quietly turns himself in
and wonders where he went wrong